Ucrania el invierno pasado esta pequeña
ciudad al suroeste de kiev era el lugar
de unas 5000 personas ahora tras nueve
meses de guerra está en ruinas los pocos
residentes que quedan luchan por
satisfacer sus necesidades diarias
es difícil para todos quiero mi casa
quiero vivir en paz y que mi hijo y su
novia tengan un lugar donde vivir porque
ahora no tienen vida no es vida
se están construyendo rápidamente
viviendas de emergencia y será
necesarias las temperaturas invernales
en Ucrania caen a menudo hasta los 25
grados bajo cero y permanecen así
durante semanas al sur en gerson
recientemente liberada las fuerzas rusas
expulsadas siguen bombardeando la ciudad
mientras los trabajadores de
Electricidad se apresuran a reparar las
líneas eléctricas bombardeadas cuando
empezamos a reparar el bombardeo
comienza inmediatamente parece que nos
ven o que alguien les informa ha
ocurrido muchas veces reparamos las
líneas eléctricas y al día siguiente
tenemos que volver a repararlas
el invierno también ha llegado aquí los
residentes dependen de la luz de las
velas para iluminarse mientras que el
gobierno ha instalado tiendas de campaña
de emergencia a las que la gente puede
acudir para calentarse y cargar sus
teléfonos
Moscú ha respondido con semanas de
bombardeo sobre las instalaciones
civiles de Electricidad y agua luego del
éxito de la contraofensiva del ejército
ucraniano una campaña destinada a
quebrar la voluntad de la población de
seguir resistiendo y que según la ONU
puede ser un crimen de guerra